to me all the movies are very personal
when I look at them and I don't mean
like I'm some crook all right but the
thing about it though is like you know
this group of friends will look at it
and be like Oh Quinn I can't believe you
talked about that you know you know and
this old girlfriend because they
identify with experience that's when you
know you found somebody really special
and you can just shut the [ __ ] up for a
minute comfortably share silence you
know it's like it's you know it's it you
should be semi-embarrassed about certain
people seeing your movie I think when
you're finished if you're working on a
personal level or else the work is not
authentic well I mean I don't want to
make that blanket a statement but I
guess for me I guess yeah yeah you're
not doing you're not you're not
extending yourself unless you're
bringing all of that you've got to I
mean you basically I mean
you should have this little voice inside
of you saying tell the truth yeah tell
the truth tell the truth all right
reveal a few Secrets the truth is your
life experience exactly that's the truth
is I know it